Thursday's Nintendo Direct brought us
plenty of news cloud is coming to smash
bros the new starfox will arrive in
April and the NEX elder will be a Wii U
game after all but in our hearts and
minds the most wonderful and best story
is the return of pokemon red blue and
yellow on 3ds in their latest Nintendo
Direct Barry finger first since the
passing of nintendo president a Nintendo
Direct host Satoru Iwata the company
announced the pokemon red blue and
yellow will come to 3ds early next year
these are the original games recreated
as true to the originals as possible in
Telo said though it's unclear if
glitches or other oddities with the
originals have been addressed players
can trade and battle their pokemon
wirelessly which means the link cable
days of the 90s are nothing but a
distant memory the new versions will
launch on the eshop on februari 27th
which is the same day that pokemon red
launched for gameboy back in 1996 in
japan if you missed out on the nintendo
direct or if you want to catch up with
what was announced we've got all the
news over on gamespot com i'm kate and
thanks for watching
you